In the fall of 2019, a subway
fare hike in Santiago, Chile set off
some of the most violent protests in
Latin America's recent history.
In what the media dubbed the social
outburst, rioters destroyed
churches, metro stations and
tollbooths.
The protests culminated in the
election of the 36 year old leftist
president Gabriel Boric, who has
pledged to nationalize Chile's
private pension system, raise taxes
and create a more green economy.
Even before that, protesters went
after the Chilean constitution
itself in a nationwide referendum
held in October 2020, 78%
of voters opted to replace it.
On September 4th.
They'll return to the polls to
approve or reject a new draft
constitution which, if passed,
could bring a tragic and decisive
end to Chile's so-called economic
miracle that turned the country into
a model for how free market policies
can benefit the poor.
The current constitution was adopted
in 1980, when Chile was still one
of Latin America's poorest
countries.
Over the next 40 years, the
government tamed inflation,
privatized industries and slashed
tariffs and red tape, which caused
its GDP to soar and poverty
to plummet.
Staples of modern living like TVs,
refrigerators and washing machines
became a feature in almost every
home.
Here's the problem, Chile's 1980
constitution was adopted during the
military dictatorship led by General
Augusto Pinochet, who took control
of the country in a murderous 1973
coup.
Because of this, some say the
Constitution is illegitimate.
The best way to address problems
with the document is not to scrap it
altogether, but to revise it,
which is exactly what's happened.
Since a return to democratic
governance in 1989, the Chilean
constitution has been amended 140
times.
Rewriting the constitution as an
elected body has been doing over the
past year has predictably created
a feeding frenzy for political
interests looking to codify special
rights and privileges into the
nation's most important legal
document.
The Economist describes the
country's draft constitution as a
fiscally irresponsible left wing
wish list.
It bans job insecurity, expands
welfare programs, mandates gender
parity in all public institutions,
and grants social rights that would
expand the role of the state in
health care, education and housing.
The document permits property and
asset seizures by legislative decree
without compensation for rightful
property owners.
It constraints the mining industry,
eliminates school choice and would
disband the Senate, making it easier
for the executive branch to
circumvent the opposition and enact
its agenda.
These provisions are spelled out in
almost 54,000 words,
which is about seven times as long
as the US Constitution.
Unlike that document, which has been
in place since 1788,
the Chilean draft constitution
focuses on expanding state power
rather than constraining it.
Chile's draft constitution is even
longer than Venezuela's, which
was redrafted by Hugo Chavez's
administration during his first year
in office and set the stage
for the country's socialist
revolution, descent into
dictatorship and ensuing economic
collapse.
Venezuela has had 26 constitutions
in a little over two centuries.
In general, the practice of
scrapping and rewriting
constitutions helps to explain
Latin America's relentless political
turmoil.
The constitution provides legal
stability and predictability, like
a computer operating system.
Tampering with any foundational code
create security holes that are
easily exploited by political
opportunists looking to amplify
their own power and overturn the
established order.
Even if Chileans reject the new
constitution, and thankfully polls
indicate that they probably will,
Boric can choose to start the
process again with the election of
yet another constitutional assembly
to draft yet another version that
could bring years of chaos, economic
stagnation and legal uncertainty.
Now that Latin America's free market
experiment and economic miracle is
coming to an end, hopefully
the rest of the world can learn from
the experience of Chile once again.
Beware leftist pipe dreams.